Héber bonjour vous êtes écrivain grand
reporter ancien diplomate votre dernier
livre chez Kalman Levy dans l'oeil de
l'archange on est clairement là dans la
dans la mise en scène il faut lever tous
les doutes
février de l'an dernier donc avant
l'invasion de l'Ukraine et donc là il y
a une sorte de fissuration de pouvoir il
était temps de reprendre un petit peu
les rênes en main ce qui est le plus
important pour plus en fait c'est la
fidélité de l'armée l'armée n'est pas
pucciste évidemment Moscou ne serait
jamais tombé en tout cas on a parlé de
ralliement de certaines unités même
minoritaire très marginale mais quand
même c'est un signal très très fort pour
Poutine et les tétons évidemment de
reprendre les choses en main sous les
lits pour finir on peut dire que Poutine
a joué avec le feu parce que il a essayé
d'instrumentaliser à la fois Wagner à la
fois l'armée de Tchétchénie de cadiroc
donc les carottis contre l'armée ou avec
l'armée donc ce n'était pas très bien vu
et c'est moi qu'on puisse dire par les
militaires les généraux russes en tout
cas là on sait très bien que dans cette
guerre et d'une manière générale pour la
pérennisation de son pouvoir Poutine ne
peut pas se priver de soutien de cette
armée est-ce aussi un message aux
Occidentaux Poutine félicite encore une
fois l'armée russe après des troubles
dit-il dans le résultat aurait été
inévitablement le chaos ce sont ces mots
hier il s'est posé en garant de la paix
intérieure mais aussi de la stabilité
est-ce là un argument envers les
Occidentaux une Russie sans Poutine avec
à sa tête des forces non l'étatiques
c'est forcément source d'inquiétude
notamment pour l'arme nucléaire
oui certes Poutine a intérêt si je peux
dire instrumentaliser à mettre cela en
avant se plaçant d'ailleurs à un moment
comme une victime la même dit que
c'était la faute des Ukrainiens les
occidentaux que d'avoir eu ce coup de
chavorter mais en tout cas il sait très
bien qu'il y a deux choses il y a deux
informations qui ont été apportées par
les Américains auprès du FSB donc les
services de renseignement russe et
auprès de l'armée c'est que d'une part
vous ne gagnerez pas vous les Russes
cette guerre c'est pas les la perdre en
tout cas vous n'avez pas la gagner et
puis deuxièmement par par une sorte de
de bruit ambiant Poutine C par ses
services que les Américains ont très
peur du chaos le chaos donc une sorte de
démantèlement de la Russie avec un
scénario à la ex Yougoslavie et donc là
il revient en force en disant attention
moi j'incarne justement l'ordre moi
j'incale la stabilité avec non seulement
les organes de sécurité dont le FSB le
FSO qui est une autre compte de sécurité
de protection de personnalité avec
éventuellement les ministres privées de
Gazprom avec bien sûr gardien qui est la
garde nationale et puis deuxièmement
avec l'armée donc il veut être un petit
peu le personnage qui incarne non
seulement l'ordre dans son mal à la
stabilité mais le vrai chef des armées à
l'heure actuelle mais est-ce à même de
faire évoluer la position des
Occidentaux vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine
non pas forcément parce que évidemment
je ne pense que cela ne va pas faire
baisser la garde du soutien les
bioccidentaux à l'Ukraine parce que vous
savez on est vraiment sur le fil du
rasoir il n'y a pas eu de gains majeurs
avec cette contre-offensive
ukrainienne depuis quelques semaines sur
le front russe et les Ukrainiens n'ont
pas profité de ce flou et qui est
important quand même sur le front du
Dombasle pour les soldats russes
pourquoi parce que rappelez-vous pour
cette colonne de chat et de blindés et
de voitures de Wagner monter vers bureau
neige ensuite vers Moscou on était où on
était sur la M4 c'est une route de
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres qui
montent donc de ressources sur le dos
qui est tombé je rappelle comme un fruit
mûr c'est quand même une ville d'une
part d'un million d'habitants
deuxièmement le centre opérationnel des
forces russes donc en Ukraine donc c'est
vraiment le commandement de toutes les
opérations qui se déroulent de l'autre
côté de de la frontière et bien
finalement Wagner n'a rencontré aucune
résistance et bien cette autoroute M4
est quand même la route qui permet de
ravitaillement des troupes parce que
évidemment il y a
toutes ces routes secondaires
perpendiculaires qui permettent d'aller
sur le bon base donc évidemment c'était
un signal très très fort mais en même
temps on voit mal les Occidentaux
baisser la garde sur la fourniture de
mission et de munition et d'armement
tout en sachant effectivement et vous
avez raison que il y a toujours cette
autre ligne rouge un moment elle était
c'était le chiffon rouge brandi par
Poutine à de multiples reprises sur le
l'utilisation de l'arme nucléaire
évidemment est pris à son propre piège
parce que il n'est pas question qu'il
utilise quelqu'un la Russie serait
totalement classifiée c'est à détruite
et puis deuxième menace aujourd'hui
c'est le chaos c'est-à-dire grosso modo
c'est moi Poutine ou le chaos mais pour
finir on peut dire aussi que on est dans
un début comment dire de de préparation
à la succession Poutine pour plein de
raisons d'abord il a 70 ans on peut même
en temps de paix envisager évidemment à
une autre Russie dans 10 ans dans
quelques années et là peut-être que ça
peut s'accélérer en fonction de cette
fragilisation du pouvoir quotidien
est-ce que ça peut passera forcément par
Wagner alors bon on peut en douter il y
a aujourd'hui une double réalité autour
de cette milice d'un côté Poutine qui
dit vouloir absorber Wagner au sein de
l'armée de l'autre côté Wagner qui
affirme que son siège à
Saint-Pétersbourg bien il fonctionne
normalement il y a un paradoxe il y a
quelque chose qui cloche là non oui
c'est difficile de réintégrer cette
armée c'est une armée de détenus pour
80% des troupes de Wagner donc on était
libérés des prisons on le sait par
Prigogine qui lui-même a été détenu
lorsqu'il avait une vingtaine d'années
et qui était libéré au bout de 8 à 9 ans
pour éviter incarcéré pour je rappelle
escroquerie corruption mais aussi
incitation du mineur à la prostitution
c'est quand même pas rien donc j'allais
dire que c'est détenues sont presque
fidèles au chef qui les a libérés après
vous savez Poutine à les mémoire longues
d'abord parce qu'il s'agit d'un ancien
allié qu'il a créé lui-même qui a trahi
donc lui-même employé ce mot de trahison
de traître donc l'ancien allié n'est
plus loyal et puis deuxièmement parce
que c'est un ancien colonel du KGB donc
du FSB et le FSB dans ces
précédentes incarnation c'était la
Tchéka les guêpe ou le NKVD et puis le
KGB le FSB a toujours
[Musique]
pérenniser cette présence de Wagner sur
le territoire africain alors parlons de
l'Afrique puisque ça nous intéresse
beaucoup ici à France 24 notamment
vous le disiez Sergueï labroff hier a
confirmé que les activités de Wagner
continueraient en Centrafrique et au
Mali ça veut dire qu'il confirme qu'il y
a bien des miliciens russes à Bamako ce
que le régime Pucci n'a jamais lui
avancé et confirmé oui bien sûr ils sont
présents ils sont présents directement
indirectement il y a très souvent des
officiers du guerrou de guerrous c'est
l'équivalent du FSB donc côté militaire
donc ce sont les services de
renseignement militaire qui permettent
aussi la connexion dans son bac le
pouvoir russe mais aussi avec la
logistique parce que il y a pas d'armée
logistique de Wagner qu'en privé me
disait qu'il avait ses propres camions
de ravitaillement ses propres avions
c'est fou en dehors de son jet privé de
quelques hélicoptères et encore donc en
Afrique il n'est pas encore plus de
l'Etat russe mais en même temps il y a
un partage du gâteau énorme pourquoi
parce que c'est une sorte d'échange
entre cette présence et cette
sécurisation de certains appareils
politiques en Afrique avec la promesse
de pouvoir exploiter donc des richesses
par les diminuerais des mines d'or des
de métaux rares en Afrique aussi du
boira et d'autres exploitations et là
c'est un partage du gâteau
extraordinaire pour la réussite et aussi
tous les comment dirais-je tous les
héritiers potentiels de Poutine c'est à
dire aussi les chefs des organes de
sécurité avec des outsiders des
challenger potentiels autour de Poutine
donc là il y a un intérêt certain de la
part de la Russie à maintenir cette
présence donc de Wagner sur les
différents états africains mais est-ce
qu'on sait si les représentants les
lieutenants Wagner entre guillemets en
Afrique sont forcément des hommes qui
sont proches de trigognes est-ce que
Wagner peut continuer à vivre à
continuer à faire ses affaires en
Afrique sans Prigogine
oui c'est une bonne question je peux
penser que le pouvoir russe va
recomposer on va dire la société
concorde et la société Wagner mais en
tout cas il est tout à fait possible de
satelliser les opérations
les Opex les opérations extérieures de
Wagner en Afrique et même de les
parcelliser d'État à l'état et que le
gayrou et que le FSB et que d'autres
organes de sécurité peut-être même
l'armée russe s'occupe qui du Soudan qui
de Djibouti qui l'humani qui d'autres
États africains avec bien sûr encore en
vie en vue c'est cette partage un gâteau
qui est
un gâteau colonial ou néocolonial c'est
exactement ça on est on est dans un
colonialisme à Rebout avec cette
présence de de Wagner en Afrique
évidemment il y a 7 correspondances
directes avec l'exploitation des
richesses du sol africain et là ça
intéresse beaucoup évidemment les
organes de sécurité en Russie
actuellement vous nous dites que vous
vous lisez la presse africaine est-ce
que quelle est la tonalité de ce qui
ressort après cette rébellion est-ce
qu'il y a un doute qui s'installe sur la
crédibilité de ce partenaire au Mali en
Centrafrique on sait que Wagner
intervient surtout pour assurer la
protection de certains dirigeants qui
craignent d'être déstabilisés d'être
renversé par des groupes armés
de certains journalistes d'opposants des
sociétés civiques donc des ONG
humanitaires et autres en Afrique qui
commencent à comprendre évidemment qu'il
y a une vraie exploitation une vraie
colonisation on va dire de certains
territoires en Afrique via Wagner et
donc derrière via la Russie et puis
évidemment après certains appareils
d'État qui au contraire maintiennent
comme au Mali leur volonté d'avoir la
présence de Wagner contre d'ailleurs la
présence française et après il est
possible aussi j'entends quelques voix à
droite à gauche il y a pas encore
d'analyse de fixe de ma part là dessus
il y a quand même certains conseillers
du dirigeant en Afrique qui disent
peut-être que la présence française
n'était pas si mal que ça malgré les
critiques que l'on pouvait lui faire en
tout cas il n'y avait pas directement
volonté d'exploiter nos ressources dans
tel ou tel pays donc ça il peut y avoir
une remise en question de la part des
États africains en tout cas pour la
présence de sécurité elle sera
pérennisée au moins par le guérous
c'est-à-dire en fait par les services de
sécurité militaires de l'armée Russie
merci infiniment Olivier Weber c'était
passionnant vous êtes écrivain grand
reporter ancien diplomate et votre
dernier livre dans l'oeil de l'archange
chez calmant Kalman Levi je ne sais pas
si on va pouvoir revoir
la DLS voilà dans l'oeil de l'archange
le livre d'Olivier Weber qui est
intervenu sur notre antenne merci à vous
en tout cas